[Music]
I just want the everybody thank you so
much critic what are you doing no you're
my guy he can smell teach my god Linkara
why in Star Trek circles he's known
simply as link art yes the ultimate Star
Trek nerd he has heard about my Star
Trek month he wants to do a crossover
review with me on Star Trek insurrection
I won't let no no no all his stupid
little nitpicking is that nobody cares
about I'm not going to spoil my review
and I have a perfect hiding spot
he will never look for me here something
would happen while we were laughing -
yeah like we'd be interrupted or yeah
like someone would interrupt what
laughing yeah
so you want some coffee
very lovely thank you yes
might as well see what's on the
television there hello critic start the
review last time in the good Star Trek
movie the card goes through a Borg
identity upset with stopping his old
archrival even though he'd never really
been that obsessed before he follows the
board back in time to stop man first
contact with the Vulcans after ripping
off Moby Dick because that's what Star
Trek likes to do
Picard defeats the Borg Queen data goes
through his I want to be human bullshit
again and first contact is still made by
the farmer from big will Star Trek
continue to score big with audiences I
don't care I get paid either way
[Music]
and now we come to the final film in
star trek month star trek insurrection
with special guest star
Linkara hello adoring fans I've come all
the way here on my spaceship to talk to
you about the most hated of All Star
Trek films wait a minute this was the
most hated I thought was either like the
first one or five that was the most
despised that may be the case with other
fans but me personally this is my least
favorite in the entire franchise so you
need me here or else you'll screw this
review up like you've done so many times
before what what I've ever screwed
something up in your Battlefield Earth
review you said the cyclos never have
explosions on their planet when that's
not what they said in a movie it was at
the air they breathe reacted violently
to radiation my god you're defending
Battlefield Earth no I'm pointing on the
fact that you never get details right so
we're going to do this together so it
gets done correctly so let's not waste
any time let's dive right into this well
it's kind of just a duo thing but it's
my room yeah okay I guess I'll just go
stand slowly in the corner Star Trek
insurrection so we open on the Shire as
we see a peaceful alien people called
the Baku taking care of their planet
funny how these people who don't believe
in machines have an irrigation system
set up for their crops it's almost as if
machines are helpful or something and on
top of that the original series got away
with people who looked exactly like
humans because it was a low-budget 60 TV
series this is a multi-million dollar
movie by some damn forehead bumps or
something
we see their Starfleet personnel in
invisible suits keeping track of the
people in the city my god it's Jambi
mekka lekka die mecha die you ho
he takes a phaser and reveals the
Federation's base which is remarkably
close isn't it wouldn't it make more
sense to monitor them in space so that
nobody bumps into it what did they do
the construction and invisible suits
they never heard the invisible
bulldozers put it together but heck with
that we have this subplot that goes
nowhere I'll get to the ride they are
eating the floral arrangements on the
banquet tables I guess they don't
believe in cocktails before dinner but
they paid you terian perhaps we should
have a chef without a lightbulb summit
vinaigrette something that goes well
with chrysanthemums wow those four lines
in the road dedicate to the plants gives
you some idea of the thrill ride
whirring for with this movie remember
they have a significantly less advanced
technology than ours they only achieve
warp drive last year the federation
council decided to make them a
protectorate so quickly
two of our losses to evolve in the
Dominion the council fields we need all
the Allies we can get these days
remember this I'll have a tangent on it
later what do you see the word Dominion
wrong or something yes but that's beside
the point we'll get to it later captain
mr. Warren what the hell are you doing I
was at the men's are coming a little
late Geordi can it wait room I don't
think so every it doesn't matter you're
here we'll catch you
welcome aboard the Enterprise Captain
Picard may I welcome you in the
time-honored tradition of my people so
we need stuff with the oompa-loompa
Queen and she partakes in the tradition
of making bald men look like Dorothy
from The Wizard of Oz okay sir should
have been back by now they were on the
schedule to observe tobacco village for
one week but Picard acontece I would
have gone with Gianluca Julia okay
that's pretty good
it's told about data and had to go
figure out what's wrong Geordi would you
set up a secure comm link yeah
I kept it Harv's Alex lo we medically no
fatal competence last here did you ever
have a chance to read my paper on
thermionic transconductance would you
excuse me what's that guy I don't know
will you seen all the showing have you
ever popped up not that I'm aware of
well maybe he'll explain it in his next
scene he doesn't have a next scene you
mean he just completely
[Music]
are you around
commander data attacked us an initial
sculpture yesterday I know what data
means to start please all look but our
crew is at the mercy of those people on
the planet if our first attempt to
capture data failed I will terminate him
at least give us one more movie before
we kill him
all right come out come out wherever you
sir it's something that's my mother yeah
well that was a thrilling backstory yeah
I wonder what other character insights
were the glance over you know this
reminds me of when I was a little girl
in the last I see how he responds to
threats I wonder how he would respond
when a maneuver I don't really
understand they figure out singing to
him will somehow break his programming a
British star is a sword it's all hit no
shut panting asleep cringy should flame
and his brow should hurl an ocean
antenna slit should occur okay has
perfect just become a musical between
rubber wear your bow life forms and this
I've heard less singing in Sesame Street
I mean what Star Trek fan would actually
enjoy it is I should flash with a head
board fire is brow it's gonna be wrong
he never should bow down to a lot of
classics all the profits of the singing
surprisingly does work as the team beams
down where they see the PACU playing a
friendly game of CG ball we were under
the impression they were being held
against their will
the artificial life-form were not
allowed him to leave apparently he was
taken ill there was a phase variance in
his positronic matrix which we were
unable to repair I think the captain
finds it hard to believe that we'd have
any skills repairing positronic device
well yes as you clearly explained that
you don't use technology our
technological abilities and not apparent
as we have chosen not to employ them in
our daily
lives we believe that when you create a
machines do the work of a man you take
something away from the man then how can
you know the latest technology don't get
me wrong I understand studying
technology but how can you keep up with
the latest technology on a planet
forbidding technology without any
goddamn technology magic shot at one
time we explored the galaxy just as you
do you have warp capability capability
yeah and where can what God taker accept
away from here yeah I guess the Star
Trek has taught us anything it's that
space is pretty boring I'm sorry but I'm
not behind this at least not in the way
these office jerks are wanting it first
of all you have machines we saw your
irrigation line you idiots and those
clothes look pretty damn well tailored
for people who don't have the ability to
manufacture them properly second this
movie built this place up as paradise as
Eden or perfection however their
philosophy is the complete opposite of
what Star Trek's stands for Star Trek in
the end is about how advanced technology
has done us so much good allow us to do
so many great things and that the future
is a bright one partially because we
watch for nothing this movie however
tells us we need to get back to nature
and be smug hippie jackasses who reject
technology and machines in favor of
being soaked in bread that we don't
believe in any other colors for our
clothes success Brown yelling Karim I
sorry I really hate these people they
sent me off with the hate Amish people
to know they hate me but at least the
Amish have religious reasons for
rejecting technology these guys are just
dumb we see them using tools and in the
end what is technology but just advanced
tools on the bright side it's not like
we have to deal with them that often
they're the focus of the movie but the
atmosphere of the planet starts playing
with the crews molecular structure which
makes everybody get all four lagging a
bit a word peu British Worf grows a
pimple the card gets all energetic and
half the cruise drive acting like horny
kids give up yuck
I never kissed you with a beard before
huh
[Music]
who's that that's with a clip from the
show oh god don't tell me yes I have
every episode of Star Trek in my ships
databanks I intend to use them
throughout this review whenever the
continuity seems off come to think of it
we could probably use a few seems to go
- go back I'll take that as a no all I
know is that he was functioning normally
until he was shot in its failed state
since Anabaptist failsafe evidently
moral subroutines took over all of its
basic functions but you're saying that
he's still neo the difference could be
right and wrong in a sense that's all
yes because the ethical battles of right
and wrong are now easily programmable
facts in the future
hey data which of these is ethically
sound abortion stem cell research death
penalty but they get data back to normal
and he takes them to the last place he
remembers before his programming went
wacky I believe I know what is causing
the neutrino emission yep no machines
except for this giant machine looking
thing here to drain the lake what's that
just common as a garden oh isn't it
oh did I mention they have a dam -
that's right a dam and these are some
damn big immigrants they discover an
invisible ship with a holodeck replica
of their town in it another thing that
they could have just worked on in space
but some bad guys see them and start to
attack
[Music]
you know for as exciting as this all is
I honestly just keep thinking back to
whatever happened to that blue guy
what were you series of thermionic
transconductance much more
thought-provoking questions than the
rest of this movie is asking oh why you
kidding me
he's water technology now are you
resisting the shackles of h2o and on top
of that it turns out she's had plenty of
time to learn how to swim we discovered
that several of the adult there are over
300 years old that's what the metaphasic
radiation of the planet does yeah what
the hell's her Excuse in 300 years you
never learned to swim I just haven't got
around to it yet you are stupid so
basically the Federation wants to use
the planet as a means to find cures and
other medical miracles sounds good so
what have they talked to these people
about working together
no they just plan to beam them off the
planet when they're asleep odd well I'm
sure now that they know the Baku are
willing to help others by Legum state a
plan No they see it as their home they
hate technology we have technology
therefore they hate us okay well I guess
that's legit seeing how it's their
planets not talking about yet
technically the planet is under
Federation control and they say they
came there 300 years ago from their own
home planet so they know don't squat
well the weather hopefully just keep me
pretty cure for death holder without
that so the car can make speeches like
this some of the darkest chapters in the
history of my world involved the force
relocation a small group of people just
as coaches have been destroyed and every
other force relocation throughout
history oh really is that why you
participated in at least two for three
locations and guess what one of them was
a group of Indian and he was going to do
the exact
same plan as they're doing here do you
know how long we have searched for home
I believe that I can help you to find a
new home but hey these are white people
and I'm Native American so it's totally
different I guess yeah that's true
there's a group of stretchy faced people
that are looking to harness the planet's
power because they're dying yet these
selfish jerks are like you're yours an
electric razor
you deserve to croak we're only moving
600 people how many people does it take
that row before it becomes wrong 601
obviously we'll be able to use the
regenerative properties of this
radiation to help billions and I'm sorry
but I got a reference my clips again
this is what I was referring to before
at the same time this movie came out the
series Deep Space nine was on and during
that series the Federation was at war
with a powerful enemy called the
Dominion and the Federation was losing
badly and according to their projections
if the Federation loses 800 billion
people will die and I'm sorry but John
doesn't Star Trek have a particular clip
for this kind of thing
I need to the many outweigh it means you
can whew I'm sorry but I'm completely on
the side of the bad guy here critic
Oh what I'm done the movies over no
who's you then all right so Picard
decides to go down alone if he's going
down alone why should he have all those
guns he can't carry them all the box who
already says they won't use weapon well
because he knows his crew is gonna throw
the same bullshit that every Star Trek
crew throws I don't want you to come
we're coming okay
oh and don't forget that totally out of
nowhere trailer line from data saddle up
lock and load so they're leading the
people away from the town wait isn't
that what the bad guys wanted anyway
kind of doing them a favor aren't you
I'm just wondering where the Sun is in
the solar system we never saw it in any
of the space shot but then the villains
come in to hit them with darts and force
them to get beamed out well why don't
you just beam them out regularly
[Music]
but they get away I'm guessing they just
sort of cut off screen and then there's
somewhere else as data tries to comfort
the boy who just lost his father
machines ever play I play the violin
look if you want to know it's like to be
a child you need to learn to play oh
yeah he sounds traumatized hey know
everybody treats grief differently some
choose to accept this by not realizing
they have it at all we also see picard
and boring woman who won't be any future
movie so it doesn't matter start to hit
it off I should warn you I've always
been attracted to older women
[Music]
how are you dying as
uh yeah questions lots of questions yeah
this is science fiction at least some
questions have to be answered nothing
nothing at all okay she's a wizard
anyway we see more Megaman robots catch
up with them and they try hiding in a
cave thanks for saving us with your
technology by the way we hate technology
well that's going on the bad guys are
attacking the enterprise while Ryker
tries to escape them
you ever notice a pattern in these
movies the car leaves the ship and my
car always destroys it access panel
steering column red fur helm controls
the manual joystick Ryker is piloting
the ship with a joystick just become a
half at wing commander game folks not
let's be fair a real video game version
of this film would be far worse do you
think the moving of six hundred people
to save 800 billion people is ethically
sound you have selected yes you are of
course wrong gable but they then get
stuck in a cave and a bunch of rocks
fall on top of that boring lady the car
then says dialog that even Rick Astley
wouldn't put in one of his love songs
stay with me
help me find the power to keep you in
this problem stay with me stay with me
system like to love this moment but then
something remarkable happens I guess she
slows down the moment so that the others
can arrive in time oh I thought she was
going to have an emotion I said
remarkable not a miracle oh thanks for
saving me with your medical technology
by the way I hate technology I'm sorry
I'm still wondering what happened to
that blue guy were the important series
when they change the dynamics of
anything so in a twist or at least I
think that's what they're calling it it
turns out that the dying race called the
SONA
are the exact same race as the baku they
just left the planet so they didn't have
the healing powers of the baku had so as
you can see the ethical standpoint of
this movie is so weak that they had to
make up other reasons to hate the bad
guys well you can also tell he's the
villain by the fact that he looks like
Salieri skin melting oh yeah I forgot
that definitely Abraham isn't it okay I
think even he forgot he was at Murray
Abraham in this picture moving them is
one thing killing them all or one date
two more than you go so it's a little
confusing but pretty much everyone keeps
ship hopping and they fooled the SONA
by beaming them onto a holodeck which is
programmed to look like the bridge of
their ship it just happened to have that
program in there no more questions link
are unable to comply injector assembly
one has been deactivated
he screams like a baby elephant and then
goes over to the collector device for
the Rings then Picard beams over there
and they have a really crappy action
scene bla bla bla
you're really going to risk igniting the
exhaust all right I will useless than
ever
[Music]
the Picard has beamed up the shipments
destroy did we get our one funny line in
the movie the soda crew would like to
negotiate a ceasefire it may have
something to do with the fact that we
have three minutes of air left so bored
by the rest of us I came to bring myself
to life at bat we also see that data has
discovered playing seven years of
character development on a TV show and
three movies and it all comes down to
play don't forget you have some little
fun every day start by not watching this
movie
[Music]
Linkara I'm not gonna lie I do think
that's the worst one you see even if you
took out the ethical discussion the film
as a whole is just of for the action is
dull the effects are dull it's paint
more like a really lame episode than it
is a feature film it just feels like
nothing was accomplished and even the
worst Star Trek movies left me with
something at least one or two
interesting moments but this is totally
forgettable and has nothing backing and
in a way for a Star Trek movie you could
argue that is the worst crime you could
ever commit oh wait we still have all
the problems of nemesis to go through
and I'm not just talking cono here's
your info calamara harm you don't hide
won't you turn off the TV Oh plenty it
should put in little fuck alright sci-fi
guy you've been there long enough I
think you learn your lesson what lesson
I didn't do anything you won't go back
in the corner no well thanks everybody
for joining me for Star Trek month I
hope you enjoyed
alright alright I'll quickly go over
Star Trek nemesis this is the film that
everyone says is the other badge fresh
film but to be fair I don't think it's
that bad it's got some annoying scenes
and way too much action but the whole
idea of majoring literally versus
nurture I thought was kind of
fascinating I liked the idea that the
card had to battle his younger self and
that in a different environment maybe he
could have been something entirely
different and the relationship between
the two I think in many respects is
actually kind of heartbreaking to me
that's the glue that held the movie
together
is it good technically on a storytelling
level probably not I have to admit I
enjoyed watching it for the most part
but yeah I'll admit as an ending for the
next generation franchise it probably
wasn't all that it couldn't I mean it
could have been a hell a lot worse it
could have been Star Trek interaction
well I
[Music]
you